with crime up in many parts of the
country some people are looking for new
ways to protect themselves so this
morning we're going to help you out
showing you devices that can help you
stay safe some even look like jewelry
and can do everything from making very
loud noises to setting off silent alarms
rachel rothman is here she's the chief
technologist and executive technical
director for good housekeeping institute
she joins us to demonstrate some of the
products and explain how do you choose
what's best for you rachel it's so good
to see you thank you so much for having
me i know that good housekeeping floor
and all the testing you guys do on the
29th floor of the house tower very very
cool stuff so you decided to focus on
protection because crime is on the
uptick here yeah we were just saying
really scary times we're in right now so
anything to give a little peace of mind
is what we're here to do so what do you
think we should be looking for in a
device so that so when we're testing in
the lab key is ease of use you want to
make sure it's intuitive it's something
that you're actually going to wear and
know how to use when it's operating um
so we have some really great pictures i
like that you have bracelets and
necklaces that actually look pretty good
so what are the scenarios in which you
would use this yeah so you may be going
out for a run or a jog in central park
you may be going on an online date you
may be walking home from class late at
night any of those scenarios and we're
not saying to you not online date you
might need a security device but with
the person you're going on the online
day when you are in real life
yes yes these are not sprays right it's
not a weapon no these are not sprays
none of these are going to inflict
actual harm but they're going to be able
to send out alerts and do and some of
them do so how do they work so this
first one here in visual wear i'm
wearing it right here too all you do is
you double tap it and you set in advance
and it will send out to up to five
contacts your location it can also alert
emergency services 911. so you choose
it's all up to you what you wanted to do
so there's an app so there's a button on
the back you tap it twice and it's gonna
send out those alerts and this company
works with adt so you know it's a
trusted reliable say rachel what does it
say so it will give the location where
you are exactly so it'll know where the
fact that you're sending it means that
you obviously think you need help so
it could be your mom your dad a brother
or sister and then also emergency
services you mentioned exactly so you
can select either goes to those people
it goes to 911
and then we have the flare so
these are bracelets and cuffs and what
it does a lot of similar things so it
operates over bluetooth and it's able to
connect with your phone so it has your
location but with flair you can also set
a pre-recorded call so they have these
about 10 12 different options for it so
it can be an incoming call and you
choose what it's going to say so it can
say mom it can say dad it can say
roommate whatever it's going to say and
then it'll give a pre-recorded call
something like
you know the pet is in is having an
emergency you need to get home right now
something along those lines so if you're
in a scenario and you're not feeling so
safe it's a really subtle way for you to
be able to exactly something to help you
get you out yeah they're really nice
looking so invisible has over 20
different skus so they have bracelets
and and necklaces they have even
scrunchies so you can choose something
that's really aesthetic that's going to
work with whatever you're wearing and in
a really discreet way it's giving that
added assurance a scrunchie that could
send information yes exactly yeah okay
the key chains here on the end so these
don't require any tethering to your
phone it's all handled within this so
this is called birdie and this one is
going to set off a really loud sound on
a strobe light
let's warn people are you ready this is
very loud it's going to get loud so it's
going to be like an ambulance driving by
loud
i'm holding on to it
i was trying not to make it go as far we
want to get there
and also a strobe light so again if
you're walking home late at night you
can just be carrying this with you if
you're going on a run you don't need
anything else to draw attention do you
think that's better than a pepper spray
so it really depends upon the scenario
and who you are and also where you live
um so in certain places there are
actually restrictions along pepper spray
so while it's legal in all 50 states you
may not be able to purchase it there may
be restrictions on quantity and again as
we were talking about that inflicts
actual pain so if you're not confident
in it you may accidentally spray
yourself or
cause more harm in the situation and
you're uh you're on your uh watch you
said that on your iphone and on your
watch that there are safety apps so a
lot of people don't realize this but
built into your iphone or android device
you actually have emergency services so
if you hold on to the power button and a
volume switch it'll actually initiate an
emergency sos um so it's really i didn't
know that on all iphones on all iphones
what and what so if you hold on to the
power button and a volume up yeah and if
you hold it and press it it'll initiate
that sequence as well and you can also
set in your health app emergency
contacts as well so it offers those
capabilities but you have to make sure
your phone is charged you have to make
sure your location services are on all
of those important things i know we
think about adults when it comes to
products like this but kids right yeah i
have a 12 year old daughter i like that
30 it's a great gift to give to kids so
they're just walking home from school
they have something again stay vigilant
but it's a really nice added backup i
like it
thank you so much thank you so much for
having me of course we'll be right back